how do you explain
the mechanisms of china today
where there's
quite a bit of sort of
flourishing of businesses and so on it's
a very peculiar kind of entrepreneurship
they got away from central control
uh but it's it's but they still manage
central political control but
diversified economic control so there's
a you could it is possible to draw a
line between politics is possible and i
think in some ways china's more likely
to survive as a society going into the
future than western uh capitalist
societies are um so i think uh
if if we do the karl marx the the
foreground and the background
you can um
centralize
the politics the the
humanity
the subjective stuff
and then
uh distribute the objectives you've got
to have the goods yeah and that's what i
mean the big change from malta's deng
xiaoping was the
characterized in that little saying that
i don't care whether you have a black
cat or a white cat so long as it catches
mice
and there was a level of pragmatism to
the deng xiaoping revolution over mao
and madame in particular
and that was manifest in the desire to
get as much of those western goods as
possible and i was actually in china in
81.
a group of journalists there as i
mentioned earlier for a tour we we ended
up
going to the sichuan free trade zone
and that gave us an idea of why
china was going to succeed because they
had a rule that you couldn't just come
in and exploit the cheap wages you had
to also have a chinese partner
and within five years the chinese
partner had to earn 50
of the business which is huge and it
gives you an idea of the reduction in
wages these american corporations are
looking at they'd shut down the factory
in the what's now the rust belt of
america it might be paying somebody
there you know
at that time maybe two dollars an hour
and they come across to china and
they're paying two cents an hour
so they were the enormous amount of
wages that they dropped they were
willing to have forego half the profits
and the ownership of the firm so what
the chinese were doing wasn't just
exploiting their labor force
it was also building a capitalist class
and that meant that you had this that's
where all the you know chinese
corporations have come from so they were
building a capitalist
system
within a socialist command political
system
and that worked
and it's still working so there was the
centralization of the economic stuff the
gauze plan approach
i think that was where the soviets
failed
and and what the chinese realized after
what they went through under mao
was you have to have that capitalist
period but they weren't going to abandon
the communist control politically the
country at the same time
and that worked out brilliantly and
there's a huge amount of innovation
taking place in china today
and they also will do gigantic
infrastructure projects
you know breathtaking planning going
into that if you've you would have seen
videos of you know building a skyscraper
in a day
uh the planning that has to go into that
the pre-preparation is necessary is
enormous so there's a real respect for
engineers as well in that society which
does not apply on the west
what do you think about the from the
western perspective the destructive
effects of centralized
control the populace of the ideas of the
discourse of the censorship and the
surveillance all those things so and
it's a bit like we were talking about
russia to some extent beforehand uh with
centralized versus decentralized
corruption
and when you had it
the centralized
political stuff means you know you can't
criticize within china but as long as
you don't criticize you can do what you
like and how destructive is that to the
human spirit
um from the american perspective
i i found some pretty deals destructive
before
i've been to china quite a few times
over my life a lot in the last not for
about four years but the six years
before that a few visits
and i'd be staying in
second and third and fourth tier cities
so you know populations of only four
million people which is quite small on
chinese standards
and
i had a lot of happy people that i was
interacting my girlfriend at the time
her social circle um
and like you can feel when people can't
discuss a political issue for example in
thailand you can't discuss the king
okay they still have you know
less majestic laws so you can actually
be jailed for discussing the king and
you can feel that to some extent and it
is a political issue in thailand now but
in in china what i got back from most
people it was a bit like a benevolent
big big brother okay but then when you
get things out like the lockdown which
is applied recently then you get the
the failings of the soviet system is
still there in the chinese system in
that
um the easiest way to avoid criticism
as a underling carrying out instructions
of people above you is to carry those
instructions out to the letter
beyond what the people actually want you
to do at the top
so we had a classic illustration of that
when i took these journalists
there was a news report saying that uh
china's output of light industry had
grown by 17 in the previous year but
heavy industry had fallen by seven
percent and we just did don't compute so
we kept on asking why did this happen
every time we asked a question this is
back in 81 the answer would be the
initial answer we followed the directive
to the central committee the communist
party of china
we finally got a guy to elaborate and
say what that was he said well this
central committee sent out a directive
to promote light industry
so what did you do quite unquote we
stripped heavy industry factories and
turned them into light industry yeah
okay now that's destructive of
everything okay and that's the overlay
that you've still got sitting over the
top of of china but a huge part of the
industrialization was simply saying uh
produce whatever you you you can make
goods market them sell them and you get
that
innovative component of humanity is
respected and the goods turn up and
everybody's well fed food in america
rush genre is far better than food in
america um so in terms of material
satisfaction
uh and and freedom
really for example enjoy dancing i mean
we went to um
um i think somewhere in shanghai and
there's this line of people
involving a woman who would have been
close to her 90s and a kid who was about
six or four partying it up partying it
up in the open air and doing this
chinese collective dancing you have to
be really careful about that kind of
thing so
in terms of measuring
the flourishing of a people
by
looking at their
happiness
i have so many thoughts on this but i'm
imagining north korea and if you
talk to people in north korea
i think they would say they're happy
no well let me let me let me try to
complete this argument
not an argument but a sort of
challenge to your thought
which especially in the bigger cities
because they don't know the alternative
so what else do you need there's enough
food on the table
we have a leader that loves us and we
love him
we're full of our hearts are full of
love
our table
is full of food they would say because
it's enough food um
what else do you want from life no i
think okay like that's so let me sort of
chat because like that's an alternative
i mean i've i've one time in romania so
let me sort of complete that sorry
because i'm taking the most challenging
when there's centralized control of
information
that you don't know the alternative
that you don't know how green the grass
is on the other side
and so your idea of happiness might be
very constrained so
uh you know you could also argue that is
happiness if you don't know
like ignorance is bliss ignorance is
bliss and then so is happiness really
the correct measure it's not for for the
flourishing it's not
but i
i mean there's actually a classic book
and movie as well which we called male's
last dancer
okay and
that is the young man explaining his
progression from being a dancer in the
cultural revolution
through to a leading dancer in american
and ultimately australian ballet
and he
explicitly says at one point that he's
told that
the chinese people have the highest
standard of living in the world
and the reaction of him and his kids
like his you know fellow six-year-old
says god it must be miserable elsewhere
in the world then
so they knew they still know they still
know there's no such thing as that
complete ignorance but what i'm talking
about is
in his experiences in china say back in
about 2016 2014
um
there was a feeling of freedom
within limits that you didn't want to
transgress because the system was
working
so if you like kind of like marriage
it's kind of like marriage hey that's a
good example
there's limits there's limits that you
can have fun within those limits that's
right okay and and people did have fun
and they did feel free but they didn't
want to go and get divorced but that
dilemma
was accommodated because the boundaries
until you started hitting restrictions
were wide
okay um and like when you look at it i
mean look at the
again with the chinese communist party
the administrators of that are often
highly qualified engineers
who can then make intelligent decisions
about what should be done as
infrastructure and so on
and you go to china and you've got
incredible high-speed rail
uh
fantastic infrastructure in internet
telecommunications and so on uh rapidly
evolving solar
there's a range of things there that are
so well done that respect reflect the
fact that the selection process that
gives you your political elite
is partially focused upon sucking up et
cetera et cetera it's still there but
it's also focused upon your
skill levels and you get people making
decisions who damn will know what
they're talking about like australia's
got a classic example the internet in
australia sucks
the reason that sucks is that the
the
labor party which is our version of the
democrats was in control during the
global financial crisis and as part of
that they wanted to bring in high uh
optical fiber connections to the house
so you'd have an optical fiber backbone
and an optical fiber you know right to
your c100 output from your home and the
liberal party fought that and said
that's going to be too expensive
to take too long to do we're going to do
cable to the node and then have a copper
network linking from a note on a street
to all the houses in the street it's
going to be cheaper and faster have it
more soon blah blah blah it was a total
technical [ __ ] up
okay and australia now has internet it's
about 50th or 60th fastest in the world
it's dreadful for the internet two
political political figures made that
decision tony abbott and and malcolm
turnbull
rivals and leaders of the um of the
conservative party we call liberal over
there now that was shitty decisions that
wouldn't happen in a country
like china
because you've got actual engineers
making the decisions they say you can't
get decent speed if you link optical
fibre to copper it's gonna so
what you get is even though you can't
make the decisions yourself
a vast majority of the decisions are
made intelligently
and therefore you expect it it's
interesting but
don't you worry about the corrupting
aspects of power oh yeah that that you
start you know
you have engineers making intelligent
decisions but at which point
does the fat king
uh start saying all these engineers are
annoying i have good internet i don't
understand
bring me the grapes well that
you know you get your caligular effects
that can happen like z from what i've
seen has got elements of that so friends
of mine
who are caucasians can get away with it
they have a game that they play at
conferences scoring how often people use
with z's name in a presentation and
giving extra points for the number of
photographs of z that turn up in the
whole thing so you've got this sort of
personality cult coming along as well
but at the same time the the planning
for the infrastructure that's being
built the social services
um the the general freedom that exists
is so great and like any chinese person
alive today like if somebody's china's
my age
uh was would have been an adult under
the
early period of the late period of mao
and god almighty that changed the
improvement they've seen in their lives
that's what they think about
so but it's the
if you just look at the history of the
20th century
your intuition would say that some of
the mechanisms we see in china now will
get you into trouble in the long term
so
it seems to be working really well in
many ways in terms of improving the
quality of life of the average citizen
in china
but you start to get worried about how
does this go wrong well yeah but at the
same time maybe i mean often people will
say you know what's your vision for the
future and what they mean is what vision
for the future do you have that i'm
gonna like
right okay now
what if you have a vision of the future
you don't like it's dreadful
well that's the ecological crisis i
think we're walking blindfolded into
well that's
uh right that that that part of the
picture we'll have to we'll have to talk
about yeah how fundamental of a problem
that is okay but what does that have to
do with the future of china it has
if you wish to impose dramatic controls
on the consumption of the rich
which would be necessary to reduce our
consumption burden so that we can get
closer to the ecological envelope we've
destroyed already
then you're going to be more likely
successful doing that with a centralized
system where people accept centralized
political control
then you are in a country where it's all
diversified and you screams freedom
every between every point in a tennis
match and i'm i've literally seen that
when i was in philadelphia some time
back
um so the ideology that accepts a
collectivist attitude
may be more successful in controlling
our reducing human consumption levels
because when we talk about democracy i
mean
who's voting here how many
horses and
elephants and
birds get to vote okay it's very what's
a bird yeah
you don't see them around here uh it's a
very human-centric vision we have of
this planet yeah and
we're going to pay a price for that
okay so you're saying to deal with
global catastrophic events
centralized
i think will work better period i mean i
like but again but there's some
centralized
stuff in the united states for example
military yeah i know no no okay all
right
now now is that now there's that feisty
australian yeah
uh so besides the military there is
that's the idea of the federal
government in the united states is that
there is some centralized uh
infrastructure building there's some big
there's not enough projects yeah
but there's some so the question is when
you deal with greater and greater global
catastrophic events
like the pandemic that we're just living
through that the government would be
able to step up
and impose enough centralized planning
to allow us to deal
sort of enable empower the citizenry to
deal with these catastrophic events in
the case of the pandemic a lot of people
argue that the uh first of all the world
but also in the united states failed
to uh
effectively deal with the pandemic on
the medical side yeah social side and
the on the financial side the supply
chain all everything in terms of
communication in terms of
um
inspiring the populace with the power of
science and all the yeah
they failed but the the ideal is that
would be able to succeed you would have
to have a small efficient the ideal the
american ideal is you have a small
efficient government that's able to to
take on tasks precisely like the
pandemic but the thing is maybe it
shouldn't have been as small as it was i
mean my favorite instance of that
actually involves the uk because the
whole neoliberal approach is about a
small efficient government okay well
small efficient government works when
you face small efficient challenges
when you face something systemic
rather than episodic then it's going to
break down and like this is i mean one
of the things i greatly respect is
taleb's idea of anti-fragile you want a
society which is anti-fragile not easily
broken whereas neoliberalism has pushed
us towards this vision of efficiency but
it's easily snapped like in the uk
i've forgotten the government minister
involved but she was
she asked her expert committee how many
this is before well before the pandemic
how many masks should we have on hand in
case of a pandemic and the answer from
the experts was about a billion
okay that's 50 masks that's 20 masks per
person okay oh that's too many let's
just make 50 million masks
that's one mask per person it was gone
in a matter of a day okay and therefore
that's why they told us well marks don't
work you know what they meant was we
don't have enough masks for our health
people let alone for you in the public
so we're going to [ __ ] you until
those masks don't really work
and then people don't wear masks and
then we've got enough masks we rush up
the production job and by the time it
comes along people have got the
skepticism about masks so who does the
uh
can you elaborate who does the blame in
that case go on the blame comes down to
the philosophy that says government
should always be small
no but do do you really think that
bigger government would be the solution
to the mass issue so let me let me push
back sort of it's possible that
that that's capitalism solves that
problem
well that's not if there's no money in
really long-term planning and capitalism
okay there's money there's money in
terms of isn't it possible to construct
is it possible for capitalism to
construct a system
that insures against catastrophic events
not when they're systemic okay the
capital you can ensure against episodic
events if you occasionally have a really
bad storm
but in general the weather's not so bad
that all the infrastructure is being
destroyed then you can share that around
on a percentage basis if you have a
gaussian distribution for your events
and you can and you don't the mean
doesn't move around too much and the
standard deviation doesn't change all
that much then insurance works fine but
if you have an if that's episodic if you
have systemic stuff where the climate is
changing completely and you're going to
wipe out your agricultural capabilities
you simply can't do insurance on that
front you can't make a profit out of
catastrophe and capitalism
you